by any measure and Carol Moore is a
giant in the field of children's
literature
she was the very first children's
librarian a position she herself created
Moore was born in 1871 in Maine and
moved to New York to attend the
librarian program at Pratt Institute in
Brooklyn
influenced by a paper she'd heard red at
the 1894 meeting of the American Library
Association more organized a children's
reading room at Pratt at this time
children under the age of 14 were often
forbidden to enter public libraries
inspired by the burgeoning kindergarten
movement more instead created a friendly
space especially for her pint-sized
patrons her children's reading room
featured scaled down furniture Reading
Nooks programming such as story times
and puppet shows and Librarians
committed to stocking the shelves with
good books
on the day more open this very first
children's reading room at Pratt a
waiting line of children curved all
around the block
Moore eventually moved on to the New
York Public Library where she oversaw
the central children's room which opened
in 1911. she managed to turn policy
around so that children were allowed to
take out books by 1913 one-third of all
the books borrowed from the New York
Public Library System were children's
books
Moore however had certain fixed ideas
about what kinds of stories were
suitable for children
she approved of fairy tales and fantasy
genres that stretched children's
imaginations and discredited with
introducing Beatrix Potter among others
to American readers
but she strongly disliked even loathed
some books that have since become
Undisputed Classics of children's
literature
and because of her work which also
included book reviewing Moore was a
powerful gatekeeper who could damage
sales and even ban certain children's
books from the shelves of the New York
Public Library
one of the children's writers more
vehemently disliked was EB White
Moore's reaction to White's first
children's book Stuart Little was hard
to Fathom given the fact that she had
urged him to write the book in the first
place
before Stuart Little was published in
1945 Moore had obtained the early page
proof and she wrote to White telling him
she felt the novel was
inconclusive and not affirmative
she argued that the novel was not fit
for children to read
Stuart Little she said was unruly and
his story failed in every way to
correspond to time-honored patterns for
fantasy
Moore didn't stop there she wrote to
White's editor and insisted the book
should not be published and Then
followed up with a 14-page letter to
White's wife Catherine Sergeant Angel
White
Catherine was no pushover she was a
groundbreaking writer and for many years
the only female editor at the New Yorker
so when Moore urged Catherine to
pressure her husband to cancel the book
Catherine ignored her fortunately the
whites had enough cultural clout of
their own to get Stuart Little noticed
in the literary World despite Moore's
objections
but seven years later more popped up
again to complain about what many
readers consider EB White's Masterpiece
Charlotte's Web
more praised other just published
children's books in her Roundup column
but then she turned to Charlotte's Web
she declared that she herself had grown
up on a farm in Maine and conceded that
white portrayed farm animals with great
Beauty and understanding she liked the
character of fern but thought her mother
was an idiot
then Moore committed the book critics
cardinal sin she faltered white for not
writing the book she would have written
Moore wrote Fern the real center of the
book is never developed the animals
never talk they speculate as to
Charlotte her magic and mystery require
a different technique to create that
lasting interest in spiders which
controls childish impulse to do away
with them
more is disdain by the way wasn't
exclusive to books by E.B white she
absolutely loathed Margaret Weiss
Brown's 1947 classic good night Moon and
this loathing carried weight
from 1947 through
1972 the New York Public Library System
did not contain one single copy of
Goodnight Moon that was because Moore
who'd already been forced to retire by
the time Goodnight Moon and of course
Charlotte's Web were first published
still exerted such power at the New York
Public Library that those books simply
weren't ordered
I've gone into Moore's story because she
was such a powerful figure mostly for
good in the emerging professionalization
of children's literature as a genre in
the 20th century
but I also want more story to remind us
that the Banning of books any kind of
books can happen undercover so to speak
we know about Anne Carol Moore's extreme
prohibitions because of her prominence
as a librarian but there's no way to
know how many times books have been and
continue to be quietly exiled from
library shelves because someone with a
bit of power takes offense
as we continue with this lecture
focusing specifically on children's
books we now consider Classics it's
helpful to remember that the Bannings
I'm discussing are the ones we know
about because they took place in the
public sphere of school PTA and Library
board meetings
[Music]
thank you